what you can see here is we've got x
squared plus y squared equals 17 and y
equals x squared plus 3 since we know
what Y is equal to let's go ahead and
put that in place of Y in the first
equation
that's the substitution method so what
we're doing is we're trying to combine
these two equations so we just have one
variable one equation so let's go ahead
and do that we've got x squared plus the
quantity x squared plus 3 squared equals
17 now remember when you do a
substitution you want to put it in
parenthesis you want to treat it like a
group so it's this quantity squared so
now what we're gonna do is we're gonna
oil this out which if you want you can
think of when you square something it's
like having to of that quantity okay and
so now we're going to do is we're just
going to do the foil method or you can
distribute twice like so so that gives
us x squared plus X to the fourth plus
3x squared plus another 3x squared plus
9 equals 17 what I'm going to do is I'm
gonna get everything on one side of the
equation set it equal to zero so we've
got X to the fourth plus let's see 6x
squared plus 1x squared which is 7x
squared okay and if we subtract 17 from
both sides we get negative 8 okay so now
we're going to do is we're going to
factor this it factors to x squared
times x squared which gives us X to the
fourth what two numbers multiply to
negative 8 but add to 7 that's going to
be positive 8 and negative 1 because you
can see 8x squared and negative 1 x
squared is positive 7x squared now all
we have to do is set each group equal to
zero and solve so we're going to go
ahead and do that we've got x squared
plus 8 is equal to 0 and we also have x
squared minus 1 is equal to 0 here if we
add 1 to both sides we get x squared
equals 1 and if we take the square root
of both sides remember when you take the
square root of both sides you get two
answers positive or negative 1 and over
here if I subtract 8 from both sides I
get x squared is equal to negative 8 and
if I take the square root of negative 8
you actually get imaginary numbers right
so this actually comes out to positive
or negative 2i root 2 when you get
imaginary number that just means that
there's no real solution for this
particular part here this is an
extraneous
Rutan extra or false solution what we're
really trying to do here is when we look
at x squared plus y squared equals 17
this is actually a circle and we look at
y equals x squared plus 3 this is
actually a parabola and what we're
trying to do is we're trying to find
those points of intersection of these
two graphs right so here this just gives
us a false answer this is not a point of
intersection but over here we have x
equals 1 we also have x equals negative
1 if we take 1 and we put it back into
either one of these two equations either
for this X or this X I'm going to do the
bottom one because it's a little bit
simpler 1 squared is 1 plus 3 is 4 so
that's 1 comma 4 if we put a negative 1
in negative 1 squared is 1 plus 3 is 4
so we're getting 1 comma 4 and negative
1 comma 4 and you can see those are the
two points where this parabola and the
circle intersect so that was example 1
let's look at example 2 now here we're
gonna use the elimination method and
when you do the elimination method what
you're trying to do is you're trying to
add these two equations together in such
a way that either the X's cancel out or
the Y's cancel out so you just end up
with one equation one variable right so
the key here is let's see do we want to
limit the axes of the Y's I think the
Y's are gonna be a little bit easier if
I multiply this top equation by 2
that'll give us negative 2y squared and
we add it to positive 2y squared those Y
Squared's are going to cancel we'll just
have an equation with X's in it so let
me go ahead and do distribute the two
that's going to give us 2x squared minus
2y squared equals negative 10 so I just
distribute the 2 so the entire equation
left side right side and then result I
put as this equation here now if we add
straight down we get 5x squared the Y
Squared's cancel and we get 20 if we
divide both sides by 5 we get 4 and if
we take the square root of both sides
remember you take the square to both
sides you get two answers plus or minus
two right so what we have here now is
when X is equal to two let's see well
let's go ahead and put two let's put it
back into this top equation right here
so we have 2 squared minus y squared
equals negative 5 2 squared is 4
okay and if we subtract 4 from both
sides we get negative 9 and if we
multiply both sides by negative 1 we get
Y squared is equal to positive 9 and if
we take the square root of both sides we
get plus or minus 3 so what that means
is when X is 2 y could be 3 or when X is
2 y could be negative 3 but remember how
X could be positive 2 or negative 2 so
let's look at what happens when you put
negative 2 in so negative 2 squared
minus y squared equals negative 5 gives
us 4 minus y squared equals negative 5
subtract 4 again you can see we're
getting the same kind of setup here we
have subtract 4 from both sides we're
getting a negative y squared is equal to
negative 9 y squared equals positive 9
if you multiply both sides by negative 1
and if we take the square root you can
see we're getting plus or minus 3 again
so that means it can be negative 2 comma
3 or negative 2 comma negative 3 so here
we're actually getting four solutions
and the reason for this is is because
what we have here is we actually have a
hyperbola and a parabola and it's going
to look something like this it's going
to be like say for example you have I'm
just going to do kind of a rough sketch
here but let's just say for example your
hyperbola could look something like this
and your parabola could they say
parabola ellipse your ellipse could look
something like that and you can see that
there's actually like 4 points where
they're crossing here so 4 points of
intersection and so that's why we got 4
solutions here there was only two points
of intersection so it kind of depends
you could have a 4-2-3-1 0 you know they
might not intersect at all so great job
if you like my teaching style and you
want to check out some of the courses
that I've put together to help you in
your math class I've got one for algebra
1 algebra 2 a CT math as well as SAT
Math you can check out right down there
in that lower right hand corner to go
over and see what courses have available
I look forward to helping in the future
videos I'll talk to you soon